Monday morning started with hundreds
gathering outside the court in Goodman
Sudan's largest city eagerly following
what was happening behind the heavily
guarded walls some demanded the death
penalty for the 41 National Security
Service officers they were charged with
the manslaughter of a metal chair a
schoolteacher in the eastern state of
Casilla in court the judge brought the
more than 12 weeks of trial to an end
the defendants are facing charges of
manslaughter which falls under article
130 which carries a death penalty the
first defendant to the 27th will all
receive the death penalty the 31st and
33rd are also sentenced to death
defendants 29 and 30 a cleared of
charges where the rest are sentenced to
jail the verdict was welcomed by a model
Harris family his torture and death in
custody provokes anger in schools all
over Sudan and a wave of protests
demanding the end of the 30-year rule of
President Omar al-bashir he was
eventually deposed in April following
months of unrest it was initially
sparked by rising food prices and grew
into a wider revolt demanding radical
change Bashir has been charged with
inciting and participating in the
killing of protesters we consider this
case to be a turning point in Sudan's
history many institutions in the past
both the judicial and Security used to
cover up the crimes committed by
security forces this is the first time
we have security forces put on trial for
torture it's the first ever we've had a
verdict on a large number of those
involved in the crime the security
forces and intelligence services used to
be a fortified Bastion that were
untouchable after what seemed like a
long wait the verdict was greeted with
celebrations since the formation of a
transitional government the demand to
bring to account those involved in
killing protesters over the past year
has been driving demonstrations for many
Monday's verdict is only the start of
the response for those calls a response
they say must include more trials of the
accused to bring justice to other
victims activists say at least 250
protesters have been killed since the
start of their revolution
12 months ago Sudan's prime minister
has set up a committee to investigate
the deaths including minal for arson
sala de madrid gun islam we welcome the
verdict today but we're also waiting for
the trials for those who killed my son
we filed a complaint and we've brought
forward witnesses but we haven't heard
of any trial yet we'll be following that
up until we bring justice for my son and
others who were killed
we will die fighting for that justice
Sudanese are celebrating what they say
is the first victory and are vowing to
continue to safeguard their revolution
until all crimes are accounted for Heba
Morgan al-jazeera Omdurman